donc d'avoir avec conclusion robuste et
fiable avec un très faible écart type en
ce qui concerne les précipitations est
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
difficile que en ce qui concerne les
températures
alors une fois que je vous ai donné
toutes ces précautions d usage
je peux quand même vous donner quelques
exemples de chose qui pourrait arriver
on va prendre un premier exemple ici
vous avez une simulation qui a été
réalisé par l'inra c'est à dire le
laboratoire de recherche publique qui
est chargé de l'agronomie dans notre
pays vous avez deux cartes
la première vous donne la distribution
dû être en france aujourd'hui
vous avez donc quelque chose qui est
gradué du bleu et rouge et qui est la
probabilité d'occurrence la probabilité
de rencontrer un être
on va dire dans les forêts du coin voilà
pas si vous marchez les yeux bandés un
lendemain de fête non voilà donc en bleu
ça correspond à la distribution à
l'importance relative du être dans ce
que vous allez dans ce que vous allez
rencontrer alors ce que ça dit en gros
cette carte c'est que sur le poster du
bassin méditerranéen la probabilité que
vous rencontriez 1 red bull
sauf si vous avez un jardin d'hiver est
quelqu'un qui en a fait un bond de sai
mais sinon c'est nul et que plus vous
allez du sud ouest vers l'est et plus la
probabilité d'en rencontrer est élevé
en gros ils sont particulièrement bien
là il semble particulièrement de l'or
massif central ils sont encore à peu
près bien en or et puis plus vous allez
vers l'ouest et moins il se sent bien
mais vous pouvez en retrouver ici vous
avez la distribution dû être dans un
climat qui a été modifié avec le
scénario des missions le plus bas de la
fourchette donc le scénario émission
constante ou quasi constante et bien
vous voyez que dans l'essentiel du pays
la friperie exactement des façades
maritimes du pays
il n'est plus possible de trouver dû
être il est plus possible non plus d'en
trouver dans le couloir rhodanien dans
la bretagne et dans le nord vous avez
encore la possibilité d'en trouver mais
pas beaucoup
et vous avez un réservoir voilà il en
reste en montagne ici et puis dans les
vosges et le jura et puis ailleurs dans
ma foi il y en a plus énormément
il fait bien voir que
dans ce genre de simulation c'est
malheureusement la partie blanche qui la
plus robuste
c'est à dire que là vous êtes
complètement sortis des paramètres
climatiques nécessaires à la vie dû être
vous êtes raisonnablement sûr qu'il y en
aura plus ailleurs vous en savez rien
parce que ce genre de simulation ne
prend pas en compte
l'apparition éventuelle de ravageurs la
compétition entre espèces les incendies
ou le fait que les gens iront tout coupé
parce que rapide pétrole je vous
rappelle ce que je vous ai déjà dit au
moment du cours sur le charbon c'est le
charbon qu'à sauver les forêts
françaises
on était en train de couper toutes
jouées à disponible pour alimenter les
forges et le charbon est apparu et a
fait qu' on n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout
de la déforestation
donc ce genre d'évolution ça ne tient
que pour autant que les hypothèses que
vous faites soient raisonnables et en
particulier ce que je vous dis ce que je
viens de vous dire c'est qu'il ya des
tas de trucs qui en général ou font
plutôt que ça pourrait être pire que
mieux ne sont pas pris en compte dans ce
genre de simulation avec les mêmes
réserves
vous avez ici une autre simulation qui
porte sur l'air de distribution du sapin
voilà donc vous avez aujourd'hui des
sapins dans les massifs montagneux
essentiellement en 2100 avec un climat
qui serait modifiée par le scénario des
missions le plus bas encore une fois
donc là il n'est pas question d'un
scénario charbon et c'est vraiment le
scénario des missions le plus bas eh
bien on brûlait le sapin a disparu de
quasiment partout où ils ont retrouvé
encore un peu dans le massif central il
a disparu de quasiment partout sauf une
partie des alpes les alpes du nord et
une petite partie du genre voilà cette
affaire avec les mêmes réserves que ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure
parce que si d'ici à 2100 vous avez cinq
étés 2003 ou un peu pire
l'un derrière l'autre vous pouvez très
bien avoir quelque chose qui je vous
rappelle que l'homme par exemple est un
art qui a disparu des forêts françaises
personne ne sait si c'est le
réchauffement climatique mais c'est
quelque chose qui est allé assez vite
aux quinze jours un parasite qui est
apparue une maladie et les ormes ont été
éradiqués de france
encore une fois ce genre de processus
n'est pas prise en compte dans ce genre
de simulation je vais vous donner un
autre exemple de processus qui s'est
déroulé il ya pas longtemps dans notre
pays
vous avez une maladie des végétaux qui
s'appelle l'oïdium qui est un petit
champignon qui apparaît sur les feuilles
et qui a tendance à les rabougrir ça
empêche les feuilles de bien se
développer comme ce parasite apparaît
sur un arbre qui a déjà formé ses
feuilles
ça lui bouffe un peu les failles
existantes mais ça n'empêche pas de
vivre quand ce parasite apparaît sur les
bourgeons parce que la température a été
plus que nantes l'hiver et donc il a pu
se développer plus tôt eh bien ça
empêche considérablement plus les
feuilles de se développer
et si ça apparaît plusieurs années que
successives labeaume heures parce qu'il
est incapable de reconstituer ses
réserves
mais voilà vous avez typiquement un
exemple dans lequel j'avais une espèce
d'effet transistors 1
c'est à dire que un petit effet sur une
petite bête en l'occurrence qui ne fait
que décaler de 1 ou 2 mois la date à
laquelle la petite bête commence à
produire ses conséquences ça peut avoir
des gros résultats et causé la
disparition d'une espèce qui avait là un
point de faiblesse c'était son talon
d'achille
ce genre de processus ça ça rentre
typiquement dans la dernière ligne rouge
que je vous avais montré sur le
transparent introductif c'est à dire
c'est des processus sur lesquels s'il
doit y avoir une mauvaise surprise
on le saura quand la mauvaise surprise
sera là c'est très difficile de
modéliser à l'avance ce genre de choses